ก็สวัสดีครับอ้าวสวัสดีครับเที่ยวหน้า
สวัสดีนักเรียนด้วยนะครับถ้ามีนักเรียนดู
แล้วโฟมสวัสดีครับโอเคอ้าวันนี้พรุ่งนี้
วันอะไรครับเนี่ยก็เยี่ยมวันนี้เป็นวัน
อาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์ไม่ไปทำงานใช่ไหมวันที่
มีให้ไปทำงานว่าวันนี้วันหยุดมันหยุดบ่อย
ๆทำงานแย่ไม่ต้องทำงานวันนี้เอาที่ไม่
ปกติวันหยุดไปไหน
ปกติวันหยุดในๆมันหยุดไปไหนก็อยู่บ้านนะ
คะอ๋ออ๋ออยู่ที่บ้านไม่ได้ไปไหนอ๋ออ๋อ
ต้องการอยู่อย่าอยากจะหักใช้นี่ก็
อยากไปเหมือนกันอยากไปเที่ยวแล้วเนี่ยอ่า
เดี๋ยว
อาหารไปไหมไปไหม
เดี๋ยววันวันวันหยุดวันหยุดหน้าเสาร์หน้า
ถ้าเราไปเที่ยวไปเที่ยวกันไหมอ้าวันเสาร์
วันเสาร์หน้าๆเสาร์หน้าวันเสาร์กับวัน
อาทิตย์ 2 วัน
วันเสาร์
วันเสาร์กับวันอาทิตย์
วันๆครับๆวันสองวันอ่าเดี๋ยวเราไปเที่ยว
กันน้องอยากไปเที่ยวที่ไหน
เกมอยากไปเที่ยวทิ้งที่มันมี Two เขาที่
มีภูเขาใช่ไหมถ้ามีภูเขาด้วยถ้ามีภูเขา
ด้วยอ้ามีที่นึงมีที่ 1 ที่เพียงพี่ก็
อยากไปเที่ยวเหมือนกันเพราะว่าเพื่อนที่
เคยไปแล้วมันสวยมากน่ามีพูดใช่ครับที่
เชียงใหม่ไปเชียงใหม่กันไหมไอ้สาอย่าไป
เชียงใหม่กันเออใครเอาไปนะโอเคไป
เชียงใหม่กันไปซัก 2 วันใช่มั้ยเดี๋ยวเรา
ไปเชียงใหม่ปี 2005 เพราะฉะนั้นเผาวัน
อาทิตย์วันเสาร์กับวันอาทิตย์ 2000 เคถ้า
งั้นเดี๋ยวเราต้องไปเตรียมเก็บของด้วยนะ
เตรียมเก็บของด้วยนะสิบของเก็บของเอาอะไร
ไปค่ะอ๋อถ้าเราไปเถียงใหม่เนี่ยเราก็ไม่
ได้อยู่บ้านใช่ไหมเราก็ต้องเอาของที่เรา
ต้องใช้ตอนที่ไปอยู่ที่เชียงใหม่ก็อาจจะ
มีเสื้อผ้านะครับสิ่งของต่างๆให้มีเสื้อ
ผ้าต่างๆด้วยอ่าเดี๋ยวเรา
อ้านี่เราเตรียมตัวเก็บของนะเพื่อที่จะ
เดินทางนะครับเดินทางไปเชียงใหม่กัน
เชียงใหม่ๆๆไปเชียงใหม่ก่อนอื่นก็จะไป
เชียงใหม่เราก็ต้องเก็บของนะเก็บของใส่
กระเป๋านี่ผู้ชายคนนี้เขาเก็บของเก็บของ
มาแล้วมีของอยู่ในกระเป๋านี้เดี๋ยวเราไป
เก็บของกันช้าใช่วิเคราะห์ไงบ้างข้างใต้
แต่ถ้ามีอะไรบ้างที่ต้องเก็บใช่ไหมอย่าง
แรกเดี๋ยวจะไปเชียงใหม่กันใช่ไหมถ้าเราจะ
ไปเชียงใหม่เนี่ยเอ่อน้องเรียนรู้ไหม
เชียงใหม่อยู่ไหน
ภาคเหนืออ่าใช่ๆเชียงใหม่อยู่ทางภาคเหนือ
นี่เชียงใหม่อยู่ภาคเหนือตรงนี้อ่ะ
เชียงใหม่เที่ยงใหม่คือตรงนี้ครับนี่ตรง
นี้เดี๋ยวพี่อ่ะที่ระบายสีนี่นี่คือ
เชียงใหม่เชียงใหม่อยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ครับแต่
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้เราอยู่กรุงเทพฯค่ะเราอยู่
กรุงเทพฯหรืออยู่ตรงนี้เราต้องการที่จะ
เดินทางไปที่ทียังใหม่จ่ายไปเชียงใหม่ 2
วันนะ
ซอยเชียงใหม่ 2 วันใช่เชียงใหม่ไป 2 วัน
เงียบดีค่ะเราจะขับรถหรือว่าจะขึ้น
เครื่องบินไปถ้าเราจะขับรถหรือจะขึ้น
เครื่องบินดีเราอาจจะขับต่อไปฮ่าๆครับอาจ
จะขับรถไปแต่วันนี้เดี๋ยวเราไปเก็บของกัน
ก่อนเพื่อที่วันเสาร์หน้าน่าจะไปเที่ยว
เชียงใหม่กันว่า
มันมีคู่เขามีภูเขาแล้วมีไข่อีกหม้อที่
เชียงใหม่นอกจากมีภูเขาแล้วเนี่ยที่
เชียงใหม่ก็ยังมีน้ำตกด้วยง้อน้ำตกข้างๆ
เป็นน้ำตกมีน้ำตกน้ำตกลงมาจากภูเขาใต้
ครับชาย 5 มีน้ำเย็นไหลตกลงมาจากภูเขาอ่ะ
แล้วเดี๋ยวเราไปเล่นน้ำกันอ่ะเราเป็นเล่น
น้ำตกกันเนอะโอเคน้องจะมีน้ำตกแล้วเนี่ย
น้องจะมีน้ำตกแล้วเนี่ยที่เชียงใหม่เนี่ย
ก็ยังมียังมีน้ำพุด้วยอ้าโรงเรียนรู้จัก
น้ำพุไหมน้ำพุที่
ที่ขึ้นมาจากพื้นดินดีๆนี้เป็นน้ำหมูใช่
ครับอ้าเป็นน้ำพุใช่ใช่แล้วน้ำภูที่
เชียงใหม่เนี่ยเป็นน้ำภูที่ร้อนด้วย
ร้อนร้อนอ้าเป็นไอน้ำร้อนก็น้ำพุร้อน
ใช่น้ำพุร้อนเราสามารถไป
อาจจะเคยเห็นเขาได้เขาปิดเอาไข่เอาไข่ไป
ต้มใต้อาหารให้
เอาไข่ๆต้มชายขับตรงนี้น้ำพุร้อนมันก็จะ
มีน้ำไหลออกมาแล้วก็เอาไข่ไปต้มในนี้
ใครก็จะสุกก็จะกินได้
อ้าเดี๋ยวเราไปกันไปที่น้ำพุร้อนด้วยไป
ที่หน้าอกแล้วไปภูเขาแต่ตอนนี้นี่ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเราไปเก็บเสื้อผ้ากันต่อ
นะครับอ่ะเก็บเสื้อผ้ามีที่เก็บของนะครับ
ของสิ่งแรกที่พี่อาร์ตี้จะเก็บก็คือ
เบียร์ที่จะต้องเอาเสื้อไปด้วย
เสื้อเป็นเสื้อตรงนี้เป็นเสื้อแขนสั้นไหน
ด้วยกันช่างอื่นที่ในตอนนี้พี่ก็ใส่
เสื้อแขนสั้นอยู่ค่ะคนถ่ายชอบใส่เสื้อแขน
สั้น
มันร้อนหากได้เพราะประเทศไทยเหนียวร้อน
เราก็เลยใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นหน้าให้พี่จะเอา
เสื้อแข่งบาสไปดูแบบสบายๆใช่หน้าน้อง
เรียนก็อย่าลืมเอาเสื้อแขนสั้นไปด้วยอย่า
ลืมเตรียมเตรียมเสื้อแขนสั้นนี่ไม่มี
เสื้อแขนสั้นมาด้วยหรอ
ยังไม่ไปวันนี้นะไปวันเสาร์นะเดี๋ยวซ้อม
เลยโอเคใส่เปรียบโอเค
อ้าแล้วก็นอกจากเสื้อแขนสั้นแล้วที่
เชียงใหม่ที่เชียงใหม่เนี่ยก็จะอากาศก็จะ
หนาวกว่าหนาวกว่าที่กรุงเทพฯ
ถ้าอากาศหนาวถ้าเราก็ต้องเตรียมเสื้อแขน
ยาวนี่แบบนี้เพื่อแขนยาวมีแขนยาวเวลาเรา
ใส่เสื้อแขนยาวเราก็จะอบอุ่นหน้าเราจะไม่
หนาวๆอ้าก็ว่าที่เชียงใหม่ตอนกลางวันตอน
กลางวันมีพระอาทิตย์ใช่สุขภาพคิดเราก็จะ
รอยท่านแดนหมอนถ่ายครับถ้าเราร้อนเราใส่
เสื้อแขนสั้นดีกว่าดีกว่าแล้วตอนกลางคืน
นะคะถ้าตอนกลางคืนมีพระจันทร์อ่ามีพระ
จันทร์แบบนี้ตอนคืนมีพระจันทร์ก็จะหนาว
กลางคืนอาหารก็จะหนาวได้แล้วเราก็ต้องใส่
เสื้อแขนยาวแบบนี้นี่เสื้อแขนยาวแบบนี้นะ
ครับดาวๆใช่แข็งยาวลงมาเลยนะครับแล้วก็มี
เสื้อแขนสั้นแล้วมีเสื้อแขนยาวแล้วต่อไป
ต่อไปเอาอะไรอีกลงจะเล่นน้ำกันเราจะเป็น
เล่นน้ำกันถ้าเราจะไปเล่นน้ำ 6 เนี่ยเรา
ต้องใส่กางเกงขาสั้นปั้นให้อ้าหลังใส่
กางเกงขาสั้นเพราะว่ามันจะเปียกอ้าเวลา
เราเปียกน้ำเนี่ยถ้าเป็นกางเกงขาสั้น
เนี่ยมันจะแห้งเร็วแล้วก็สนุกเล่นสนุก
กว่าอะไรอาหารใส่กางเกงขาสั้นเฮียตี๋มี
กางเกงขาสั้นสีแดง
น้องเรียนมีกางเกงขาสั้นไหม
นี่ค่ะอ๋อมีเหมือนกันตาสั้นเหมือนกัน
เดี๋ยว
เงียบดีค่ะทำไทยไม่ใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำใส่ชุด
ว่ายน้ำได้ไปนานขอ
คนไทยส่วนใหญ่จะไม่ค่อยใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำ
เล่นน้ำตามน้ำตกตามแม่น้ำลำคลองเราจะไม่
ใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำ
ได้เป็น Two  Piece วันพีซถ้าเป็นชุดแบบ
นั้นเราจะไปใส่ที่สระว่ายน้ำ
สระว่ายสอบถามอาๆๆเราจะไม่ใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำ
มาเล่นน้ำในน้ำตกไม่เคยชุดว่ายน้ำเล่นน้ำ
ในทะเลอะไรอย่างนี้เอ่อเราจะใส่กางเกงขา
สั้นเสื้อแขนสั้นอาไปเล่นน้ำไส้ครับ
โอเคถ้ามีกางเกงขาสั้นแล้วแล้วเราก็จะ
ต้องมีกางเกง
ขายาวด้วยอะนี่เราใส่กางเกงขายยาด้วย
เพราะว่าที่เชียงใหม่เนี่ยถ้าเราไปขึ้นภู
เขาไปขึ้นภูเขา
เราต้องใส่กางเกงขายยาว
ขึ้นภูเขาให้ถ้าเราไปขึ้นภูเขาเราต้องใส่
กางเกงขายยาวเพราะว่ามันจะมีมียุงมียุงๆ
มียุงตัวกัดๆประเทศไทยมียุงเยอะยุงมัน
เขียนยังไงคะพี่ยุ่งมีมียุงพิเศษๆๆตัว
เล็กมีสีดำจะบินมาวินมาแล้วก็แอบที่
ประเทศไทยมีอยู่ทั่วประเทศเลยที่กรุงเทพฯ
ก็มียุงเที่ยงใหม่ก็มียุงภูเก็ตก็มียิง
อยู่ใกล้ๆมียุงทั่วประเทศเลย
ถ้าว่าใส่กางเกงขายาวก็จะช่วยป้องกันยุง
ได้ยุงก็จะกัดไม่ได้ยุงกัดไม่ได้
ฮ่าๆๆครับยุงมีปาก
แหลมยาวใช่ครับ
กลัวยุงไหมน้องเรียมกลัวยุงไหม
ไม่กลัวกลัว
ๆโอเค
หน้าโอเคอ่ามีเอ่อเสื้อแล้วกางเกงแล้วอ่ะ
น้องเรียนเป็นผู้หญิงน้องเรียนก็ต้อง
เตรียมอะไรนะครับผู้หญิงส่วนใหญ่ผู้หญิง
ก็จะใส่กระโปรงใช่ครับกระโปรงหน้านี่
กระโปสีดำนี่อาจกระโปรงสีดำแบบนี้เหมือน
ที่น้องเรียนใส่อยู่เลยนี่กระโปรงสีดำแน่
นี่เป็นครับโอ่งเตรียมกระโปรงไปด้วยนะ
ครับที่นี่อุ้ยอีเสื้อมีเสื้อแขนสั้นมี
เสื้อแขนยาวมีกางเกงขาสั้นและมีกางเกงค่ะ
อย่าหายาวให้แล้วก็โปร่งล่ะครับมีกระโปรง
สั้นอ๋อปอเกาหลีกระโปรงสั้นแล้วก็กระโปรง
ยาวด้วยเหมือนกันใช่ไหมแม่แบบนี้อ้านี่
เป็นกระโปรงสั้นใช่ไหมอ่ะอันนี้นะพองสั้น
ใช้ครับ 5 กระป๋องซันโซนิกระโปรง
ยาวๆๆกันอันนี้เป็นกระโปรงยาวกันว้าววก็
สวยทั้ง 2 แบบเลยทั้งกระโปรงสั้นแล้วก็
กระโปรงยาวเลยใช่ครับ
โอเคเราเก็บเสื้อกางเกงกระโปรงแล้วเอา
อะไรไปอีกไปเที่ยวกันไปเที่ยวกันเก็บอะไร
อีกครับ
เออ
อ๋อมีอีกเราต้องเอามั่วไปด้วยเพราะว่า
เพราะว่าอะไรครับใช่เพราะที่ประเทศไทยแดด
เป็นไงแดด
ร้อนใช่แดดร้อนเราต้องใส่หมวกด้วยนี่เอา
หมวกไปด้วยนะสัม่วงไปด้วยโอเคอ้านอกจาก
นี้หมวกแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับถ้าแดดร้อนแดด
ร้อนเราอะไรไป
ตา 555 แว่นตากันแดดใช่ครับนี่แว่นตากัน
แดดใส่แว่นตากันแทนที่จะตีใส่ได้ไหมใส่
ไม่ได้โอเคแว่นตากันแดดอย่าลืมเอาไปดแต่
ว่าแดดร้อนอ่ะใส่หมวกแล้วก็ใส่แว่นตากัน
แดดเจ๊นะครับอ่ะต่อไปนะเอาอะไรอีกครับ
อยากไปเที่ยวแล้วอยากไปเที่ยวแล้วเมื่อ
ไหร่ไปทีเอาอะไรไปอีกนะครับ
มีย่าลืม
รองเท้าหน้าอย่าลืมเตรียมรองเท้าแตะไป
ด้วย
ที่ประเทศไทยคนไทยส่วนใหญ่ชอบใส่รองเท้า
แตะเพราะว่ารองเท้าแตกใส่สบายๆครับอ้ารอง
เท้าแตะใส่สบายนะครับแล้วก็สามารถเปียก
น้ำได้ด้วยเพราะใส่รองเท้าแตะไปเดินเล่น
น้ำได้ใช่ไปทำส่งค่าไปน้ำตกไอ้ครับหน้า
รองเท้าแตะเปียกน้ำแล้วก็แห้งแห้งเร็วมาก
แห้งเร็วมากตอนที่มันเปียกน้ำได้ใส่รอง
เท้าแตะสบายดีนะครับรองเท้าแตกของพี่
อาร์ตี้สีน้ำเงินเขาโรงเรียนมีรองเท้าแตะ
ไหม
มีค่ะมีด้วยเหมือนกันรองเท้าแตะของโรง
เรียนสีอะไรครับ
สีขาว
รองเท้าแตะเท้าอ๋อโอเครองเท้าแตะสีขาววาว
เหมาะกับน้องเรียมเลยรองเท้าแตะสีขาวๆ
ครับแท้สีขาวนะโอเคนี่แบบนี้มีเป็นรักแท้
สีขาวสีขาว
โอเค
เดี๋ยวเรามีรองเท้าแตะแล้วเอาอะไรไปอีก
เราจะไปขึ้นภูเขาเอา
เรื่องเอารองเท้าผ้าใบด้วยอ๋อใช่ครับถ้า
เราจะไปขึ้นภูเขาเนี่ยเราใส่รองเท้าแตะ
แล้วเดินไม่สะดวกเราเดินไม่สะดวกเลยเรา
ต้องใส่รองเท้าผ้าใบนี่พี่ตี้ก็มีรองเท้า
ผ้าใบมาให้ดูด้วยจะมีเป็นรองเท้าผ้าใบจะ
มีทำให้เราใส่กระชับนานแล้วก็จะไม่หลุด
ง่ายไม่หลุดๆถ้าเราใส่รองเท้าผ้าบ่าย
รองเท้าผ้าใบบางคู่ก็จะมีเชือกด้วย
ใช่ๆๆไปเดินขึ้นภูเขาน่าเดินขึ้นภูเขา
ต้องใส่รองเท้าผ้าใบชายครับรองเท้าผ้าใบ
คู่นี้ของพี่อาร์ตี้สีเทาสีเทา
ๆๆๆมีรองเท้าผ้าใบสีเทาไหมครับแล้วเบี้ย
ติดต้องใส่ถุงเท้าด้วยไหมคะใช่ครับถ้าใส่
รองเท้าผ้าใบเราต้องใส่ถุงเท้าด้วยหน้า
ใส่ถุงเท้าด้วยนะครับเปียตีก็เอาถุงเท้า
ไปด้วยถุงเท้านี่ถุงเท้าหน้าตาแบบนี้ถุง
เท้าถุงเท้าก็สีสีเดียวกับรองเท้าเลยเอา
สีอะไรครับ
สีอะไรครับนักเรียนเค้าอ้ะสีเทาเหมือนกับ
รองเท้าเลยรองเท้าก็สีเทาถุงเท้า
ถุงแถวก็สีเทาครับสีขาวอ๋อใช่ตรงนี้เป็น
สีขาวด้วยตรงนี้สีเทานี้สีขาวตรงนี้สี
อะไรครับ
สีแดงจ่ายตรงนี้สีแดง
54 แดงนะ
สีแดงโอเคมีรองเท้าแล้วไม่ถุงเท้าแล้วนะ
ครับมีเสื้อผ้าแล้วพร้อมที่จะไปแล้วแต่
เรายังไม่ไปวันนี้นะเอาของทุกอย่างเอาของ
ทุกๆอย่างที่เราเตรียมมาหน้าใส่อะไรครับ
ถูกต้องเอาใส่ลงไปในกระเป๋า
ต่อไปครับหน้ากระเป๋าที่อันนี้ที่เห็น
อยู่หรือกระเป๋าที่น้องเรียนกำลังถืออยู่
แบบนี้เรียกว่ากระเป๋า
เป้เผากระเป๋าเป้มันจะมีที่ให้สะพายด้าน
หลังได้อ้าแบบนี้ใช่ครับแบบนี้อาจเป็นสาย
สะพายข้างหรือสะพายให้เป็นสายสะพายสาย
สะพายน่ะเป็นเป้พรุ่งนี้เรียกว่าอะไรพี่
อ่าพรุ่งนี้หลวงพี่ๆครับเป็นหูหู
แกเป็นหูของหนูของกระเป๋ากูกระเป๋าใช้
หิ้วไส้ครับอ่านี่นะผิวให้ดูอิลหิ้ว
กระเป๋าหิ้วกระเป๋าหูของกระเป๋าและใช้
หิ้วไปหูของคนหูของด่วนตายฟังใช้ฟังแล้ว
โอเค
ๆหิวที่หูระเป๋า OK
อุ้ยมีกระเป๋าอีกแบบหนึ่งถ้าเราเตรียมของ
มาเยอะป่าวถ้าน้องเตรียมเก็บของรถเยอะๆ
เอาใส่กระเป๋าเป้ได้ไหมใส่ไม่หมดใส่ไม่
หมดใส่ไม่หมดเราต้องใส่กระเป๋าใบยี่ใหญ่
ขึ้น
กระเป๋าใบใหญ่กระเป๋าใบใหญ่นี่แหละนี้
กระเป๋าใบใหญ่แบบนี้เป็นกระเป๋าเหมือนกัน
เป็นกระเป๋าเหมือนกันครับแต่ก็หมดวันนี้
เปลือกว่ากระเป๋า
เดินอ่างกระเป๋าเดินทางใจ
ทายครับเดินทางเดินทางไปเทียงใหม่ๆเดิน
ทางไปต่างประเทศอ่ะไป
อเมริกาไปที่ต่างๆเดินห่างอาจจะกินค่ะๆ
เก็บเสื้อผ้าใส่กระเป๋าเดินทางหน้าเราก็
เดินทางไปเที่ยว
รายการนะครับถ้าพร้อมแล้วเดี๋ยววันเสาร์
นะวันเสาร์เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันแล้วเดี๋ยว
เราไปเที่ยวเชียงใหม่กันนะครับๆ 5 เตรียม
ตัวให้พร้อมนักเรียนด้วยถ้านักเรียน
เดี๋ยวเราจะไปเที่ยวเชียงใหม่การวันเสาร์
หน้าเตรียมตัวให้พร้อมเตรียมกระเป๋า
กระเป๋าเป้หรือกระเป๋าเดินทางก็ได้นะครับ
แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเราไปเที่ยวเชียงใหม่
กันแล้วเควันนี้เดี๋ยวพี่ก็จะไปเก็บ
กระเป๋าเหมือนกันนะไปเก็บนักเรียนก็ไป
เก็บกระเป๋าด้วยเดียวค่ะได้แล้วเดี๋ยววัน
เสาร์หน้าวันเสาร์หน้าเราไปเที่ยว
เชียงใหม่กันนะครับโอเคถ้างั้นวันนี้ลาไป
ก่อนครับนักเรียนบ๊ายบายครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีครับๆสวัสดีต่อนักเรียนมแถว K บ๊าย
บาย
เรียงใหม่ใครเที่ยวไปทิ้งไปเที่ยวไข่อ่ะ
ม.ค